you're like me one of your greatest
skills is overthinking given some alone
time does this person like me or not is
a meteorite going to hit the world and
destroy it you just start spiraling just
sitting idle can lead to a lot of
overthinking well what are some of the
ways to reverse that is literally to
just start working set some new goals
and set some action goals not some
results goals and this is a big key for
motivation if you only set goals that
are like my goal is 1 000 subscribers in
the next 30 days but that's not my
favorite kind of goal my favorite kind
of goal is an action goal my goal is two
uploads a week for the next 30 days and
then when you do it you celebrate you're
like honey get the kids we're going to
Chick-fil-A I'm grabbing that Polynesian
sauce I need some of that buffalo sauce
some ranch as well I just hit my goals